alrighty when we get started
um
so
welcome back nice to see you all
um
and
what have we been doing
in theory of computation
we have been talking about touring
machines
and about uh
the power of touring machines we started
uh at the beginning by
showing um a bunch of decidability
theorems that exhibit the power of
turing machines
to
calculate properties of
finite automata context-free grammars
and so on
in some cases and last lecture we talked
about the limitations of
the power of turing machines by
um
proving undecidability theorems so we
showed that
this language atm
the acceptance problem for turing
machines itself is an undecidable
problem
that was the first of many undecidable
problems that we're going to encounter
and though we proved the undecidability
of atm using the diagonalization method
as you hopefully remember
we're going to introduce a new method
which we kind of basically previewed
last time called the reducibility method
which is the way other problems are
typically shown to be undecidable
um
and so we're going to stick with that uh
for uh this lecture and also next
lecture um we're going to be talking
about um
undecidability and i think there's going
to be a few additional uh discussions
after that but this is one of the
important uh themes of the course is to
understand kind of that threshold
between decidability and undecidability
or the limitations of computation
um
so today um as i mentioned we're going
to talk about the reducibility method
for proving problems undecidable and
also for proving problems
non-touring recognizable uh turning
unrecognizable
we're going to introduce
this notion of a reducibility um in
general and we'll also talk about a very
specific kind of reducibility called the
mapping reducibility so today as
promised we're going to talk about using
reduce abilities
to prove problems are undecidable or
unrecognizable
so that's going to be our general method
oops make myself smaller thank you
i always forget
uh
thank you um
for the reminder
so
uh
so using um reducibilities to prove
problems are undecidable or
unrecognizable
and the basic way that works is we're
going to leverage another some problem
we already know
is undecidable say or unrecognizable to
prove other problems are unrecognizable
so we did a quick example of that last
time we're going to go over that example
again um just to set this set the stage
and then we're going to talk about that
in greater detail
um
so uh
as you recall from last time we had this
problem halt tm
which is the problem of testing for a
given turing machine and an input to
that turing machine whether the turing
machine halts either accepting or
rejecting but just whether it holds um
which is a somewhat different problem
closely related obviously but somewhat
different than the atm problem which is
just testing whether the turing machine
accepts
um you know it's we already showed that
atm is undecidable
um now
conceivably whole tm might be decidable
um you know it's not exactly the same
problem
but we're going to show that whole tm is
likewise undecidable uh we did this last
time but i'm just going over it again uh
i'm going to likewise show that whole tm
is undecidable we could go back to the
um the diagonalization method and do it
from scratch
but uh generally that's not what's done
generally what people do is they use a
reduceability from a known undecidable
problem um so what we're going to show
is a proof by contradiction which says
that
if
um
halt tm were decidable then atm would
also be decidable and we know it isn't
um that and that's by virtue of what we
call a reduceability from atm to whole
tm and i'll explain with the terminology
and and we'll have a chance to play with
the concept all all lecture long um so
we're going to see it in all sorts of
different vari variations um
so
as i said we'll assume whole tm is
decidable and use that to show that atm
is decidable which we know is not true
um
so quickly going through it because we
we did it already once before um
we're gonna assume
you know that whole tm is decidable
let's say turing machine r
is the decider
and now we're going to show that atm is
decidable by constructing a turing
machine s
which uses r
to decide atm
that's going to be our contradiction
so here is the machine s
the machine is you know you have to keep
in mind what the goal of s is go s is
this we're going to design s to solve
atm
which we know is not decidable so that
don't get confused by that we're aiming
for a contradiction
so we're going to use
s is typically
well there might be other variations but
for now s is going to be used to decide
atm
so we can try to figure out how can we
decide atm
and the way we're going to do it is
use our halt tm
tester that we assumed um to have
and we'll first take our
m and w where we're trying to determine
it does m accept w
and we'll first test whether m holds on
w
if it doesn't or done
because it couldn't be accepting w
m couldn't be accepting w if it's not
even this whole thing on w
um
so if it
uh
r reports doesn't halt we can reject
right off
but
um even if r says it does hold
we're still in good shape because now we
can run m on w until completion because
r has promised us that it's going to
halt
r r stated and r is assumed to be
correct
r is stated that m holds on w so now we
don't have to worry about getting into a
loop which we're not allowed to do since
we're making a decider
um we're trying to decide atm here so we
but now we can run them on w to
completion we can find out what what um
m does on w and then we can act
accordingly
so we're using the whole tm decider to
decide atm that's the name of the game
here okay um
and that's a contradiction and so
therefore our assumption that whole tm
was decidable had to be false so it's
undecidable
okay um
important to understand this
uh because this is
um sort of the prototype
for all of the other uh
uh undecidable undecidability uh proofs
that we're gonna do going forward
okay so we can just take a few seconds
here if there's something that you're
not getting about this
it's a good time to ask
not seeing many messages here or any so
why don't we go on
um but if you know if you ask i can get
to it uh next slide too
all right here we go so here's the
concept of reducibility
and i know i've taught this course many
times i know where the bumpy uh places
are in terms of people struggling with
material
the concept of reducibility is um
is a bit tricky
so don't feel bad if you don't get it
right away
you know so that's why i'm going to try
to go slowly in this lecture to make
sure we're all together
on understanding how redu reducibility
works
okay so the concept of reducibility is
that we say one problem is reducible to
another say a reducible to b
it means
that you can use b
to solve a
that's what it means for a to be
reducible to b
okay so uh i'm going to give a bunch of
sort of
informal examples of that or or easy
examples of that and and then we'll
start to use it for real
so example one this is sort of you know
really outside material from the course
but i think it's something uh you can
appreciate
you know everybody knows you can measure
uh the area of a rectangle
by measuring the lengths of the of the
of the two sides
measuring the lengths of its uh it's
measuring the length and width
uh of the rectangle
so in other words if
you had the problem of determining the
area
you could reduce that problem to the
problem of measuring uh the length and
width
of the retaining rectangle
uh so here um we you know we're taking
one problem and reducing it to another
problem you know it's conceivable that
measuring the
um length and width
is easier
um than it would be to measure the area
directly by somehow covering the space
with
uh
you know uh tiles as one way of
measuring it um
but um it tells you you don't have to do
that
the problem of measuring the area is
easier than measure covering with tiles
you can just measure the length and
width and you're done
so reducibility is a way of making
problems easier
by by
translating them into some easier
problem
so here's another example that we've
already seen we didn't talk we didn't
call it a reduceability but
um if you remember back uh a a couple of
weeks ago we were talking about the
languages anfa and adfa the acceptance
problems for you know nfas and dfas
and we gave a way of solving the a d of
a problem as do you remember you know
the turing machine simulated uh the fine
art automaton
and we solved the a nfa problem
not by doing it directly
but by converting the nfa to a dfa
and then using the solution for adfa
in fact in effect what we were doing was
we were reducing the a nfa problem to
the adfa problem
um
uh
um so
um
[Music]
let's do another example
here's a problem you know here's an
example that
you you again probably didn't think
about it this way but from your homework
um
uh
uh we had this pusher problem the
problem of determining whether a
push-down automaton ever
pushes on its stack for any input
i know a bunch of you are struggling
with that problem um working on it
hopefully
hopefully solving it in one way or
another so there's one way to solve it
is an effect by reducing the pusher
problem to the ecfg the emptiness for
cfgs
which is equivalent to the emptiness for
pdas
because
um
you can take your i mean this is the the
solution i had in mind which is a
particularly simple and short solution
of course not the only solution
um you can take your push down automaton
where you're trying to determine if it
ever pushes
and you can take the states
um that are about to make a push
and instead of making them
make a push you make them accept states
and you get rid of the original states
so now you've converted
this
automaton
to one
that
accepts every time the original push
down automaton pushes
and it accepts you know and then it has
to move to the end of the input of
course so um so it goes into an accept
state and moves to the end of the input
so every time the original machine was
about to push the new machine that
you're you're just creating here
is going to go into an except state at
the end of the input
now to test whether the original machine
ever uses stack it's enough to test
whether the new machine ever accepts a
string
okay so that's a way i don't want to
over complicate this right here and get
you thinking about the homework again
but this is a way of
reducing one problem to another problem
and you know if you're
you don't quite get this one just focus
on the other two examples i don't want
to spend time on the on the homework set
too right now so we can address that
offline or separately if you if you want
it's also the solution that's written up
in the um
the solution set that's posted on uh
on the home page by the way
um
okay uh
so getting back to let's see thinking
about uh reducibility
what i have in mind again this is sort
of rephrasing it but i'm trying to
hammer it in
that if a is reducible to b
then solving b gives a solution to a
okay that's what happens in each of
these examples
now that now how we're going to use that
we're going to use that
in the following two ways
one is to observe that if a is reducible
to b
and b is an easy problem
then a is an also then a must also be
easy because we have a way of converting
a problems into b problem you know an a
we have a way of solving a using b
so b is easy
then now you can solve a two easily
because you can solve a using b which is
easy
maybe that's the clearest up here in
example one
where measuring the area might seem at
first glance hard you could have to walk
out over the all the the whole area but
it's not hard because you only have to
measure the length and the width
um
so the fact that b is easy tells you
that a z but actually this is not the
way we're going to be using it most
typically we're going to be most using
it most typically using it in the second
version which is a little bit uh come
more a little bit more convoluted
but this is the way you're gonna have to
get used to this
so if a is reducible to b
and you know a is hard
undecidable unrecognizable whatever the
form of hard you care about
if you know a is hard
and a is reducible to b
then that tells you b also has to be
hard
why because if b were easy then a would
be easy
but we know
by us we're assuming that a is hard so b
also has to be hard
okay so there's a
you know uh um
i'm inverting the logic here but this is
logically equivalent
um so you have to mull that over a bit
um
and um we will um
uh so why don't you think about that
and uh let me just take a few questions
on the chat and don't forget the tas are
there too so you can they're happy to
answer your questions don't
don't make them sit there lonely um
all right
so somebody's asking is it possible
that a is reducible to b and that b is
also reducible to a
so that's a good question uh that can
certainly happen um in that case in a
certain sense a and b are going to be
equivalent
so solving one is going to be just as
easy or hard as solving the other one
okay so they're going to be equivalent
from the perspective of the difficulty
of solving them
so somebody's asking and this is a this
is a perennial confusion
somebody's asking so you know in in the
case for in the previous uh slide here
maybe i'll just flip back to it here
so what which direction are we doing are
we reducing atm to whole tm or whole tmt
atm
the way it's written on the slide is
what i have in mind here we're reducing
atm to haltia
because we're using whole tm to solve
atm
and that's reducing atm to holtia
just like
um you know uh
here
measuring the area
is reducible to measuring the lengths of
the sides we're using measuring the
length of the sides to solve the area
so we're reducing the area to the to the
lengths
the area to the length of the sides
but you know
i know it's
uh
you have to you're going to have to play
with it
digest it get used to it
all right
[Music]
okay so let's continue
okay so
as i said
this latter one because we're the focus
on this course is mainly on the
limitations of computation
so we're going to be looking at
uh ways of showing problems are
difficult
it could be difficult in principle like
undecidable or it could be difficult in
terms of complexity which is what we're
going to focus on in the second half but
in both cases we're going to be using
the concept of reducibility so
reducibility is going to be a theme
you've got to get comfortable with
reducibility
okay so we're going to be focusing more
on the notion that
if you reduce a to b and you know a is
hard that tells you b is also hard
okay so i'm going to try to
i'm going to say that a few times during
the course of today's lecture to try to
help you uh get it
all right here's a check-in
a little bit sort of uh
sort of off to the side but i thought it
was fun a fun check-in more
the question is some people say biology
is reducible to physics well maybe
everything is reducible to physics since
physics is
tells you about the laws of the universe
and biology is in you know part of the
universe
so my question to you is do you think
and there's no right answer here
do you think in your opinion
is biology reducible to physics
maybe yes
or maybe there are some things like
let's consciousness
which cannot be reduced to physics
um
or maybe we don't know
so
curious to know your thoughts
but it does kind of use in a sense
the notion of reducible in the spirit of
what i have in mind here
in the sense that if you could fully
understand physics
would that allow you to fully understand
biology
okay here we are we're
almost
kind of interesting
uh
though not too unexpected i suppose
uh
um so we are i think just about done
five seconds pick anything if you
want to get credit for this and you
don't
haven't uh selected yet
ready to go ending polling
here are the results
and as i say there's no right answer
here
but but
if if i had been
in the class i would have picked b
um
but i'm not surprised
uh that especially in an mit crowd that
a is a winner
all right uh
let's continue
um
okay so now we're going to use
reduceability again um this is going to
be yet another example like the whole tm
example but a little bit more a little
bit uh harder um
and we're going to be doing this you
know the next lecture we're going to be
doing more reducibilities but much
harder
so we really got to get
you know really comfortable
um
[Music]
all right we're going to show etm see
etm is the emptiness problem for touring
machines is this language empty
i'm just going to give you a machine i
want to know is this language empty or
not does it accept something or is its
language empty
um that's going to be undecidable no
surprise
proof by contradiction and we're going
to show that atm is reducible to etm
so
um these things
often take a very similar form and i'm
going to try to use the same form so if
you're feeling shaking on it at least
you'll get the
the form of the way the solution goes
and that will help you maybe plug in um
to solve problems
okay
uh
so uh
proof by contradiction um assume that
etm is decidable opposite of what we're
trying to show
and then show that atm is decidable
which we know is false
um
so
let's say we have a decider for
etm r
using the same letters
on purpose here just to try to get the
pattern for you
so our designing etm
construct s deciding atm
okay so now um
let's think about it together for a
minute before i just put it up there
um so s i'm trying to make a decider
for atm
using my decider
for the emptiness problem
okay so we have r which can tell us
whether the whether m's language is
empty
so why don't we just
i don't know stick m
into that emptiness tester
see what it says
i'm just i'm not saying this is the
solution but this is how one might think
about coming up with the solution
so are you with me we're going to take m
we have an emptiness tester
let's take m
and plug it into r see what r says
r is going to come back and tell us
whether m's language is empty or not
now one of those answers
will make us happy
why
suppose
r
tells us that m's language is empty
why is that good
well now we're done
because what s is trying to figure out
we're trying to figure out
exactly somebody
told me the answer which is correct
because now we can reject
if m's language is empty it's clearly
not accepting w because it's not
accepting anything
so if r says m language is empty then
we're good
the only problem is r may also say m's
language is not empty and then what do
we know
well not much
not much that's useful
for testing whether m accepts w we just
know m accepts something
but that something may or may not be w
okay so what do we do
well the problem is that m
is
possibly accepting all sorts of strings
besides w
which are kind of mucking up the works
they're making
th they're interfering
with the solution that we'd like
uh we'd like to be able to use r
on m
to tell us whether m is accepting w but
m is accepting other things and that's
making
the picture complicated so what i
propose we do
why don't we modify m
so that it never accepts anything
besides w
the very first thing m does in the
modified form
is it looks at its input and sees
whether it's different from w
if it's different from w it immediately
rejects
now we take that modified machine
and we feed it into the emptiness tester
now the emptiness tester is going to
give us the information we're looking
for
because if
the emptiness tester says the modified
machine's language is empty well we know
that
m is not accepting w because we haven't
changed how m behaves when it's when
it's given w
but if
r says m's language is not empty
well then it must be that m is accepting
w
because we've already filtered out all
of the other possibilities in the
modified when we've modified the machine
so let me repeat that on the slide and
write it down a little bit more formally
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
transform m to a new turing machine i'm
going to call it m sub w
to emphasize the fact that this new
machine depends on w it's going to
actually have w built into as part of
the rules of the machine
so for a different w we're going to end
up with a different machine here so this
is a machine
whose structure is going to depend on
knowing w
and that machine is going to be very
much like the original machine m
except that when it gets an input let's
say it's called x now
it that machine is going to compare x
with w
and reject if it's not equal
if otherwise
if x is equal to w it's going to run m
on w as before so it's not going to
change the behavior
when the input is w it's only going to
change the
behavior when the input is something
different than w and then it's going to
reject
all
right so
let's just um i'm going to look at two
aspects of this first to make let's
understand
the language of this new machine and
then we'll also talk about how we go
about doing this transformation um
so first of all
let just to for
emphasis uh
so mw works just like m it has all the
rules of m in it
except some extra rules
um it always at the very first step
it tests whether um x
is
equal to w or not
and if it's not equal to
it rejects
not equal to w reject so the language of
that new machine
is either going to be just the string w
when m accepts w because everything else
is filtered out
or the empty set if n rejects w
got it so it's important that you
understand
how the behavior at least of this new
machine
it's just like m except filtering out
all of the
um inputs
which are not w those are going to be
all
automatically rejected
now you
so it's also important that s
um
be able to make this transformation
but i claim that you know you'll have to
accept this if you don't uh totally see
it but
the
uh
the transformation is simply taking m
and adding some new rules some new uh
transitions and states
so that the very first thing
that
m sub w does
is it
you know just has a sequence of moves
where it's uh checking that the input
string
is equal to w or not
and if it's not equal to w it just
just rejects
so it's easy to modify m you could
easily write a program which would
modify the you know the states and
transitions of m to make it do that test
at the beginning
so i'm not going to elaborate on those
kinds of things in the future but just
for the very first time i just want to
make sure you understand that we're not
doing anything fishy here this is
completely legitimate
um thing for s to be able to do
so s can modify m
to this new machine mw
which filters that new machine
filters out all strings except for w and
rejects them
now we so s takes that new machine and
what is it going to do with it is it
ever going to run that machine no
this machine is built not for running
this machine is built for feeding into r
because
as you remember feeding m into r had the
problem that m might accept things
besides w and that confuses the result
that we get from r in the sense that
it's not useful
but if we feed m w into r
now now we're good because if r s you
know the answer the information about
whether mw's language is empty
from over here tells us whether or not m
accepts lb
if m's if mw's language is not empty
then m accepts w if m's language is
empty and rejects w
um
okay uh so let me um starting to get
some good questions here uh let me just
finish the description of s
um uh so somebody's asking here so again
this is a good this is an excellent
question um
uh
uh
how do we know that m
w
halts or
you know under on w or whatever we don't
mw may not hold on w we don't care
we're never going to run mw on anything
we're going to take mw as a machine and
we're going to feed it into r
as a description we're going to take the
description of mw and feed it into r
then it's ours problem
but r has been
assumed
to answer
emptiness testing
so we're going to just take the we just
we just took the original machine
modified it so that the only possible
thing it could accept is w
and now feed it into the emptiness
tester to see whether it's language is
empty or not
now if its language is not empty it has
to be accepting w because it's built not
to accept anything else
so we know we don't care whether mw
might end up looping
we're never going to run mw
i i acknowledge
it's a leap for for many of you so
you're going to have to mull it mull it
over
so we're going to use r to test whether
mw um language is empty
if yes
that means that m rejects w so then
we're going to reject if we know that
mw's language is empty
that must have been that m rejected w so
now as an atm decider which is what s is
m is
s is supposed to reject which is what we
we have here in the description and if
no
that means m the language is not empty
so m accepts w and so therefore we're
accepting so there's a little bit of a
twist here also
okay so let's let's take some more um
i'm expecting some questions here
so somebody's asking um how do you
determine if a language is decidable
that's what we're doing
you know
you can show a language is decidable
by exhibiting a turing machine which
decides it and you can show a language
is not decidable which is what we're
doing here by proving that no it's not
possible for a turing machine to decide
it
you know we did that first with atm
we got that contradiction
by
diagonalization and here we're doing a
reduceability um to show as as a method
of proof
um
all right let's let's uh let's continue
so now we're gonna talk about a special
kind so so far we we talked about
reducibility
we didn't define it in a precise way um
because there are several different ways
to get at the notion of reducibility
precisely um
and i'm going to introduce a one version
which is a little bit more restrictive i
mean you know somewhat more restrictive
and a little bit different way of
looking at it than we have been doing so
far
but there are going to be some benefits
to looking at this particular kind of
reducibility which we're calling mapping
reducibility
um it's going to have several benefits
for us uh immediately and down the road
but it's a little
this is also
you know a little technical so you're
going to have to
go don't uh
you know
don't don't
don't don't get scared off
you know we'll will
it it might look complicated at first
we'll um try to unpack it for you
um
okay
so first of all uh
if we have here a um
we have to first of all talk about the
notion of a computable function
so so you know generally when we've had
turing machines
you know they're they're doing yes no
they're doing except reject uh kinds of
things um so it's like a function
just sort of a computing sort of a
binary function
um
you know
for here we're going to want to talk
about turing machines that are computing
some more gener it's a function which
converts one string to another string
um so it's a it's a mapping from strings
to strings
and
um
you know
could be like the function which
reverses the string for example
um that's one uh possible function you
you could be
having here but there of course met
zillions of possible functions here and
we're going to talk about functions that
you can compute with the turing machine
and that basically means you provide the
input to the function as input to the
turing machine
and the output of the function the the
value of the function comes out as the
output of the turing machine
which let's just say it leaves that
value on its tape when it holds it holds
with the value of the function on the
tape
um
but just you know we're thinking about
algorithms here
come up with your favorite method of
thinking about algorithms it has an
input and an output and the algorithm
just computes the function by taking as
input w and the output is f of w it
doesn't have to be turing machines just
any any algorithm that can compute
something is good enough
they're all equivalent
um
and now we're going to use this notion
of a function that you can compute
to define a a kind of reducibility
called mapping reducibility i'm going to
say that a is mapping reducible to b
written with this
less than or equal to sub m symbol
you're going to see that a lot it's on
the homework also by the way
if there is some computable function as
i just described
where whenever w is in a
f of w is in b
and the way to think about it is with
this picture
so a and b are languages
written like here's a and here's b
and now there are
strings
so w might be
in a it might be out of a
and you think if you're trying to solve
a
you're trying to have a
you're trying to decide
membership in a
so you want to test whether w is in a or
not
a mapping reducible is a function
which
maps things from this space over to that
space
in a way that strings that are in a get
mapped to strings that are in b
so if you start out with w and a f of w
is in b
and if w is not in a
then f of w is not in b
it's a you know pictorially it's a
simple idea
we'll have to make sure we understand
why this
fits with our
um concept of a re reducibility but
we'll do that but anyway let's first
understand just what we're doing here
we're just coming up with a function
that can do this kind of a mapping
it sort of translates
problems which you know inputs which may
or may not be an a
into um
other strings which may or may not be in
b but sort of maintaining that um uh the
same input
property
uh that's
the same membership property so if you
start out with something in a
when you play f you're going to end up
with something in b
uh and
and conversely if you're not in a then
you won't be in b
okay um uh some somebody's asking
uh
so just a couple of questions here
not necessarily one to one no so the
function doesn't have to be one to one
there could be multiple things that map
to the same point
uh
um
and is it is there any restriction on
the alphabet no
um
so uh
before we actually get into the example
let me try to give you a sense about why
um we call this a reducibility
and the reason is
suppose we have
such an f
which can do the mapping as i described
and we also have a way
of deciding membership in b
so we have so b is decidable
so that's going to tell us right away
that a is decidable
because if you have some
input and you want to know is it an a or
not
you can now apply
f
and test whether f w is in b
so the test of w is an a
you uh you're going to instead test
whether f of w is in b and we'll we're
assuming we have a that that shows that
a is reducible to b so if you could
solve
the b problem that allows gives you a
way to solve the a problem
again we're going to say this several
times in several different ways so if
you didn't quite get it yet
you know don't don't panic
um
so here's going to be an
example sort of building on what we just
showed last time
in the previous slide atm we're going to
show how atm is actually mapping
reducible to the complement of etm
and the complement is necessary here
the computable function that we're going
to give
which is basically if you're going to
the computable function is going to
translate
problems about atm to problems about
uh etm because we're mapping reducing
atm to the complement of etf
so we're going to what we're doing here
is with mapping m and w
to the uh machine mw
kind of in a way we're boiling out the
essence boiling down to the essence of
the proof that we gave in the previous
slide
this is really the the the core of the
proof this translation of mw where you
want to know is m accepting w
to a new machine mw where you're testing
whether
mw's language is empty
and so this is the you know so remember
mw from before it's the machine that
filters out all the non-ws and rejects
them
um and the reason why this reduction
function works
um is that
mw is in atm
if and only if m sub w is in the
complement of etf
so m accepts w exactly when mw's
language is not empty
okay so m accepts w if and only if
the language of mw is not empty
so you have to mull this over a bit
realize it's
you know i i know this is
uh
can be a little tricky
but i think what we're going to do here
i think we're at the uh break the time
for the break so
uh oh no there's one more slide i
apologize so let's let's talk about this
and then we're going to have our coffee
break
uh
uh
so there are um
the reason why so this
these properties are really gonna be
getting at
what makes mapping reducible
mapping reducibility
fit with our
understanding of what a reducibility
should be
so if a is mapping reducible to b and b
is decidable then so is a
um so that
fits with what we want because if a is
reducible to b and b is easy then a is
easy so here easy means decidable
and here's the proof let's take a turing
machine that decides b and construct a
turing machine that decides a
as claimed
s operates like this
it takes its input
computes
f of that input
tests
um
uh
whether that
f
whether f w is in b using the uh r
machine that we were assuming you know
we have r deciding b
and if r
holds then output the same result
so if r accepts we're going to accept if
our holds and rejects we'll reject and
of course we're going to be simula
running r so if r is not going to be
halting we're not going to end up
halting either
okay
so the corollary is and this is the way
we're going to be using it
if a is reducible to b and b and a is
undecidable then so is b
so this is as i mentioned we're going to
be the focus on for us is going to be on
undecidability and you may want to think
about a is like the atm problem
which we know is undecidable we're going
to show the atm is mapping reducible to
some other problem to show that that
other problem is undecidable
um
and the important thing about mapping
reducibility is that also applies to
recognizing to recognizers so if a is
mapping reducible to b and b is turning
recognizable then so is a
so if you map you're reducing a to a
recognizable problem then a is also
recognizable
same proof because you can just
map your w to f of w and feed it into
the recognizer that's going to give you
a recognizer for the original language
um
the corollary is that if a
is
mapping reducible to b and a is
unrecognizable then so is b so this is
again that sort of um
inverted logic
okay so now i think where
uh oops i meant to put this picture up
earlier
uh
okay so here's a check in
um
be more of a check-in for me to see how
well you're following me
so these are some properties of
um i'll give you a minute here to think
about this some properties of mapping
reducibility
um
suppose a is mapping reducible to b what
can we conclude
does that mean that
we can flip it around
if a is mapping reducible to b does that
mean a b is mapping reducible to a
what about this one um if a is mapping
inducible to b
to the is the complement of a mapping
reducible to the complement of b or
maybe neither so you can and you can um
uh check all that apply um
multiple choice
five seconds
sorry to pressure you but
we have to move on here
pick anything
uh if you don't know okay
one two three
the end
um
okay
so
um
well the majority is correct
um
in fact it's only that uh
only b
um now
um
a
really is not in the spirit of
reducibility because um
as suggested even by the inequality sign
there um
a being reducible to b is really a
rather different thing than b being
reducible to a
um
so that that's something to we're not
going to prove that right here but um
that's something that you um could uh
think about
and uh but part b
[Music]
i think you you know if you just look
here
at the definition of mapping
reducibility
it maps strings in
to in and out to out
well that's just going to be if you
exchange in and out as you do when
you're flipping complements on both
sides it's still by the same f gonna
still work as a mapping reduction
okay so uh now we're um at our
co break so we're going to take five
minutes here
and
uh
and i'll be happy to
[Music]
take a questions here but don't forget
the tas they're here too
um
okay
okay so this is a fair question here you
know
so we had this notion of a general
reduction and a mapping reduction
um they're not the same
so
anytime you have a mapping reduction
it's going to be an example of a general
reduction but not not the other way
around
um so you know if you go back and look
at the reduction that we we offered
for halt tm that where we
showed atm is reducible to whole tm
where we started it's actually not a
mapping reduction um
uh because if we're doing something more
complicated than that's translating an
atm problem to a whole tm problem we're
kind of using it using the whole tm
decider in a more complicated way and
there are cases where that that's
actually necessary um
so we won't uh um
not not going to discuss that here but
uh it's actually kind of maybe an
interesting homework problem perhaps or
some kind of a problem to think about
um
so turing machines for fs
does does f have to be a it's not really
a decider but it has to be um well yeah
i guess it does have to be to start in
the way it always holds the turing
machines for f has to always hold it
always has to have an output so
f um
uh for the computing the function always
always has to
always has to hold
um
so someone is asking me uh
can i explain uh the the statement that
if error holds then i'll put the same
result
i just mean that in that previous slide
um or two slides back if r accepts holds
and accepts
then we're gonna hold an accept and if r
holds and rejects then we hold and
reject um so i can i don't know if this
is a good idea but we can just pull that
back here
just that was this statement here if our
holds and output the same result i just
mean that s is going to do the same you
know we're translating
an a problem to a b problem
and then answering the b problem
and we're going to give the same
value the same answer there uh so
whatever r says we're going to say 2.
that's
helpful
um
all right uh
well that's a good question here um
you know
if a is reducible to b uh why can't we
just get b reducible to a by inverting
the function that's a great question i
like that question
um
the reason is is because um
the function that's mapping onto b
uh doesn't have to be on to
surjective i guess um
so you can't always you can you're not
going to be able to if it was
um you know onto so if it covered all of
b
um
then i think then you would get a um an
invertible function and it would they
you would get the
reduction going the other way as well um
but uh though i'm not sure what happens
when you have doesn't matter if you have
collisions
it turns out that's not going to matter
but anyway let's let's not get it too
complicated here but the the problem
with inverting it is that it's not
necessarily on you know onto the whole
range
of b
uh
okay uh
so we're kind of out of time here um
is a reducible to a complement let me
just end with that no not necessarily um
it's reduceable take okay that's we'll
get there it's reducible a is reducible
to a complement um
but not mapping reducible to a
complement but a in is general reducible
to a complement so we'll actually we'll
talk i have a slide on that
uh so let us
move on
okay mapping i think it's actually this
slide mapping versus general
reducibility
so we're going to kind of contrast it to
a bit
so mapping reducibility which is what
we've just been talking about has this
picture which is i think a very useful
picture to remember um
and uh
because
the way i like to think of a mapping
reduction as a problem translator
your problem sort of in the a domain
and the mapping reduction allows you to
translate that problem into the b domain
okay and then if you have a way of
solving it in the b domain
combining that with the reduction you
get a solution to the problem in the a
domain
so that's why if a is mapping reducible
to b
and b is solvable
then a is also solvable
um
so mapping
reduction is a special kind of
reducibility as opposed to the general
notion general reducibility that where
we started
and it's particularly useful to prove
touring unrecognizability so when you
want to prove touring recognizable
unrecognizability
as we'll see the general red
reducibility is not per it's not fine
enough in a way it doesn't sort of um
differentiate things as well as mapping
reducibility does
and and and for that reason it's not
always going to be useful to prove
touring unrecognizability it's better
for proving undecidability
so what we're calling reducibility or
general reducibility
is where we just use a a solver for b to
solve a in sort of a more most general
possible way
so i'm writing that as the picture here
you you want to solve a
you're going to use the b solver as a
subroutine
to solve a
that's the way we did the whole tm a
reduction at the beginning
um
but we didn't necessarily translate an
atm problem to a whole tm problem
a little slightly different uh so you
can go back and look at that
um so i find that people struggle more
with the mapping reducibility concept
and that the general reducibility is
what people naturally gravitate towards
and so in some sense it's conceptually
simpler
and it's useful to proving
undecidability so but you really have to
be comfortable with both and especially
in the complexities
part we're going to be focusing on
mapping
reducibility so one noteworthy
difference here as uh sort of
foreshadowed by uh the
person who made this question which is a
good question
is that a is all is reducible using a
general reduction to a complement which
kind of makes sense
i mean if i can solve a cop you know if
i can test whether things are an a
complement well i can test whether
things are in a you just invert the
answer
but
a may not be mapping reducible to a
complement because there it's a very
special kind of reduction
and you just can't necess you can't you
have to just translate things in the
language to things in the language and
things out of the language of things out
of the language and they don't
necessarily allow you to do that
inversion
so for example atm
complement
is not mapping reducible to atm
because as we pointed out
anything that's reducible to a
recognizable
language is going to be recognizable
anything mapping reducible to a
recognizable languages map is going to
be recognizable
but we know that atm complement is not
recognizable we showed that before
so it couldn't be mapping reducible to
atm
you know coming a little fast i realize
you're gonna have to uh
digest it so here's the last check-in
for today
um
okay we showed that if a is mapping
reducible to b and b is turing
recognizable then so is a
and so let's just say that again
carefully if a is mapping reducible to b
and b is turing recognizable
then so is a and here the difference is
on recognize the emphasis on turing
recognizable as opposed to decidable
is the same true if we use general
reducibility instead of mapping
reducibility
so you got it so we're saying a is
mapping reducible to b using this
picture over here
and we're going to assume that b
is touring recognizable
okay so that we have a
machine which
holds an except
when you're inside b
and you know is going to reject possibly
by looping when you're not inside b
now that allows you to get
a recognizer
for a
if you have a mapping reduction
does it always work to give you a
recognizer if you have just a general
reduction
if you just have a if you just now
assume you have a b solver
and you're going to build an a solver
out of that
um
okay so mull that over while i'm setting
this thing up
well the right answer is winning but not
by much
i suppose i shouldn't be
uh
laughing about it uh but
i i knew that this is going to be
challenging so i think it's the kind of
thing you're going to have to
uh work at
um so let's see we're almost done here
um
five seconds to go
better answered i i could see a few of
you either you've left the
room
or you're uh
okay two seconds
one two three
somebody hasn't answered it
there we go so this is the correct
answer is b
it's not the same
you're not going the reason is that in a
general word i mean the picture's right
here
i mean so you mean you know this is
um
let's see
uh
you know
um how do i explain this so
uh
we know that
uh
a language is going to be um
okay if we're using general reducibility
and a is it's just reducible to b
um
[Music]
so
we know that
a language is always always reducible to
its complement in the using general
reducibility
um
[Music]
so if this were true
um
then
then we would have here
um
um
so um
if this were true when
um a
uh when a language is reducible to its
complement if the complement were
recognizable the language would also be
recognizable
that clearly isn't is not going to be
the case because
you know atm is reducible to the you
know atm complement is reducible to atm
using general reducibility
uh but um
atm complement is not recognizable even
though atm is recognizable so we kind of
have a proof that this has to be no
but as you can see i'm even getting
myself confused so um
you have to you have to stare at it um
so let's let me see we can try to take a
couple of questions see if i can clear
up people's confusion
why again okay so why again is a
reducible to its complement in the
general sense
so i'm saying
if you have a solver if you have a
decider for for for a complement it
gives you a solver for a
you just ask the solver
you know is the string in the language
or not
and now um
you just give the opposite answer if you
want to
solve the the complementary problem so
the a complement is reduced
reducible to a
you just invert the answer for whatever
the solver is doing for a but you can't
just do that inversion when you have a
mapping reduction
it's a much more
um
kind of
specific
translation that's allowed
um
so i mean the fundamental difference
between german disability mapping
disability i'm trying to bring it out
here it's just
it's just a difference in the nature of
the way things are used mapping
reducibility is a special kind of
general reducibility so you know to
answer the question about what's the
fundamental difference
you know one is using the
the problem as a subroutine and the one
is using it as a um
as a
transformation
um
anyway i think we're going to have to uh
move on here and i'm going to have a
couple of examples which may help
and then uh
uh there are also there's office hours
too after after the after the lecture
um
okay oh yeah so i wanted to again to
help you
you know i'm putting these down as sort
of templates for how do you use
reduceability um
i'm not saying you should just
uh
apply things blindly but i think it's
sometimes good just to see the pattern
and then to understand how the pattern
works once you see that once you just
start to understand the pattern of how
things are used
so to show um a language is undecidable
just
to prove a language b is undecidable
show undecidable language is reducible
to be
using just a general reduction is going
to be good enough
um
and and the template for that is assume
we have r deciding b
which you then can use as a subroutine
when you make a machine uh turing
machine or
s deciding a
and that's going to be your
contradiction if a was
originally shown to be known to be
undecidable
um
but now to prove something
unrecognizable
this kind of reduction is not going to
be is not in a sense um
uh
it's it's not
uh as enough
um because this kind of reduction allows
for complementation
which is not going to be
uh satisfactory when you're trying to
prove touring unrecognizable so you're
gonna have to prohibit
that complementation and that's really
one of the effects of the mapping
reducibility if that's sort of getting
at the essence of it
um
so we're going to show an on turing
unrecognizable a is mapping reducible to
b
often you start off with the complement
of atm which is a language we know is
touring uh
unrecognizable as we showed before
um
okay here the template is you give the
reduction function f
that computable function
um
okay so
um
so here are going to be two examples one
showing that etm is touring
unrecognizable we showed it was
undecidable before
now we're going to show it's
even
in a sense worse it's not even
recognizable
and the way we'll do that is to reduce a
a known
unrecognizable language to etm
in the emptiness
language
um
so here is the picture
that we have when we're doing mapping
reductions
we're going to map strings that are in
the complement of atm so strings that
are outside of atm if you wish to
strings where
the language is empty
to machines with the language is empty
and here
um
strings describing machines which
language is empty and here we're going
to take um
uh
atm problems
so and map them to
machines where the language
is not empty
and the thing that's going to do the
trick is going to be that same
reduction function that we saw earlier
um
you know we're going to take that
machine w from before the machine that
filters out all the non w
all the non w's
and we're going to take mw
which is
a
you know um
an atm complement problem
so the so
[Music]
so if m
rejects w then it's in the complement of
atm
and that's supposed to
map to a string a machine which is
uh where
the the language is empty okay so if mw
is in the complement of atm so m rejects
w then mw's language is going to be
empty which is what
you want to have happen
um
let me move on to my last i mean this
example is in a way kind of similar to
the one we did before and i i really
want to get to my the last example here
um
okay so
uh we'll have to just talk through this
uh rather than having it uh uh build um
let's take eqtm
that's the equivalence
problem for turing machines
do they uh
um recognize the same language
um so
this is a this is a an
a language of a new kind for us this is
a language where neither it nor its
complement are going to be recognizable
to recognizable
um
so the way we get that is
um
we're going to reduce the complement the
way we show problems are not
recognizable is re
mapping reduce
a non-recognizable language to a
typically the complement of atm so we're
going to mapping reduce the complement
of atm
to
both
eqtm and to the complement of eqtm to
show that both of those are not
recognizable
and here we're going to introduce a new
uh machine that we're going to be
building inside the reduction function
and that's going to be a
machine i'm going to call t w
and t w is a machine
that
always behaves the way m behaves on w
for every input
so if m accepts w
t is going to accept everything
if m rejects w t is going to reject
everything
so it copies the behavior of m on w onto
all inputs and the way i describe that
machine tw is it ignores its input
whatever the input is it just simulates
m on w
you could easily given m
and w you can build the machine tw
it just always runs mmw no matter what
input it gets
and so now we're going to give a
function which maps atm problems which
have the form mw so it's a atm
complement problem so this is we want to
test if this if m accepts w or not so
that's an atm complement type problem
and i want to map that to an eqtm
problem of the form
you know eqtm problems are pairs of
machines
now and where we're going to be testing
equivalents so i'm just trying to give
you the form of the output of the
reduction function f
and specifically what it's going to look
like is
when we have
m is f is processing on mw
it's going to produce two machines one
of them is going to be tw
which always behaves the way m behaves
on w
but
expanded to all inputs
and then and then
and a machine i'm going to call t reject
which just is designed to reject
everything
now look at just walk through the logic
with me
if m rejects w
tw rejects everything
and so will be equivalent to the machine
t reject
that's what we want
if m rejects w
so we're in the language atm complement
then these two machines that i produce
for you are going to be in
the eqtm language
that's what i want to have happen
for a reduction from atm complement to
eqtm
similarly
to do part two
i'm going to use make here a different f
maybe i should call it f prime
all right and you know f1 and f2 for the
two different parts so these are two
different f's i'm going to make f here
on
instead of generating
t w and t reject i'm going to have t w
and t accept which is a turing machine
that always accepts its input
now
if m rejects w
it's an atm complement
then tw
is going to reject everything and it's
going to be different from
it's companion here t accept
and so won't it'll be in it won't be an
eqtm complement
but if m accepts w
then tw is going to accept everything
and they're going to be equivalent to
t except and you will be
uh
equivalent so the here is where we're
taking
atm complement and mapping it to the
complement of
eqtm
um
too many compliments here i i realize
like compliments are confusing but
anyway why don't you mull this over um
and uh
um
just to summarize
okay yeah
you know we're out of time here but why
do we use reducing when we talk about
reductions
it's because when we reduce a to b
we kind of bring a's difficulty down to
b's difficulty that's where the reducing
comes from
um
or
we bring b's difficulty up to a's
difficulty because it's really a
difficulty relative to b that we're
talking about when we're reducing a to b
so that's why
the term reducing seems
a little out of place when we're proving
things undecidable or unrecognizable but
that's where it's coming from
anyway quick review
um we introduced the ter the
reducibility method
we defined mapping reducibility as a
special kind of reducibility we showed
etm is undecidable and unrecognizable
and that eqtm is both it and its
complement are unrecognizable
so we're out of time um i will uh shut
this down
but i'll take a few questions here
actually you know i'll stick around for
a few questions and then i'll move to
the other chat room for office hours
okay
so
question to go over
the case for the complement of eqtm
so i will do that
so that's in this slide here
okay
so this is the this is proof part two
um for the person who asked me to go
over it but i think it's
helpful for for those of you who are
might be a little bit uh shaky on this
i want a mapping reduce the complement
of atm to the complement of eqtm
by the way i don't know if this is going
to be helpful
but as we pointed out in the check-in a
while back that's completely equivalent
to
having a mapping reduction from atm to
eqtm
you can
complement both sides
and
you get an equivalent statement
maybe let's stick with the compliments
here um though
i hope that doesn't make it too
confusing
okay we're trying to show the complement
of atm is mapping reducible to the
complement of eqtm what does that mean
so that means when m rejects w
so you're in the complement
we want the two turing machines
to be inequivalent
no yeah so we're in the complement of
eqtm
so we're with so in other words we're in
the complement of atm we want the result
of the uh of f to be in
um
in the complement of eq dm
so in other words when m rejects w the
two machines should be in equivalent
right when m accepts w the two machines
should be equivalent
because when we're
not in this language so we're an atm we
want to be not in that language so we
should we should be an eqtm
so when m accepts w
we should be equivalent
when m a rejects w we should be inequal
that's what we want
let's go down here
so if m accepts w
we want
we want them to so when m accepts w want
them to be equivalent so if wham accepts
w
t w accepts everything and it's
equivalent to t except
when m rejects w
t w
um
rejects everything and so it's not
equivalent to the machine that accepts
everything
so this
i hope that's
just go through it just go through the
logic yourself you'll see why it's
working
um
all right see bye bye everyone
you